bonsoir jacques mignaux merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors à quoi
doit-on s'attendre demain
bonsoir merci de m'inviter c'est très
gentil
bah quoi angoisse attentes et bah
j'espère à une belle mobilisation parce
qu'on peut s'apercevoir que depuis que
les apps les différents appels ont été
lancés ça très très bien pris sur les
réseaux sociaux
et on a vu que de plus en plus de
corporation rejoignez cet appel sans
forcément adhérer à la cause gilet jaune
je pense notamment aux discothèques en
colère ou vtc au btp
donc c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
encourageant et bah j'espère qu'il aura
du monde et qu'on s'offre à voir et
qu'on sera entendent parce que ça fait
quand même deux ans qu'on est dehors
et bien force est de constater que on
nous a toujours pas entendu donc
j'espère que demain
là on se fera en temps d'un petit connu
deux ans dans la rue déjà entrecoupé par
ce confinement qu'il y a eu à cause de
la crise sanitaire
vous vous battiez au départ pour le
pouvoir d'achat c'est toujours le cas
demain avec ces corporations que vous
avez cités effectivement cette date là
est particulière puisque on nous a
souvent reproché de nous disperser un
petit peu trop dans les dents les
revendications et donc nous sommes en
revenus vraiment à la base les trois
revendications de base le pouvoir
d'achat un petit peu plus de démocratie
directe et participative et l'abolition
des privilèges des élus
donc on met aussi en avant le
frais des bars qui a fait on a fait un
parallèle avec le grand débat d'ailleurs
on se demande toujours où en est la
synthèse
parce que le grand débat a eu lieu mais
pas de synthèse voilà alors que nous il
ya 50 ans il ya une crise sanitaire et
les priorités ont changé le gouvernement
a mis la main au portefeuille non tout à
fait bon la crise sanitaire on peut en
parler ça a été vraiment comment gérer
pas d'une très très bonnes mains puisque
un coup les masques ce ne sont pas
obligatoires maintenant ils deviennent
obligatoires surtout qu'ils sont un
petit peu embêté parce que avec les
manifestations qui a eu l ont promulgué
la loi anti-casseurs donc on ne doit pas
être masquée dans les lieux publics il
ya maintenant c'est devenu une
obligation d'être masqué donc on n'avait
pas le droit mais maintenant d'un droit
que pour les mêmes raisons là on joue
sur les mots évidemment qu'en est-il de
dunes de la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre aujourd'hui vous avez entendu
gérald darmanin proposer un superviseur
notamment pour pouvoir utiliser le lb d
écouter entre les beaux propos et puis
là elle était du terrain ce sont deux
choses différentes
puisque je rappelle que le lbd
normalement doivent être encadrés avec
une petite caméra sur le torse de ce
qu'ils avaient la caméra bien souvent
ils ne l'avaient pas ou alors bien
souvent été en panne lorsqu'il y avait
des incidents donc dire des choses c'est
bien les appliquer c'en est une autre
maintenant si elles sont appliquées
je trouve ça très bien si on en revient
à une police qui est là pour encadrer
puis pour protéger le citoyen choses
normalement qu'elle devrait faire ça
sera très très bien mais c'est ce qu'a
dit gérald darmanin il veut moins de
violence lors des manifestations il veut
aussi flouter le visage des policiers
qu'en dites vous sur sajoo
un petit peu moins d'accord avec lui
puisque des fois ça a quand même aidé
pas mal de manifestants pacifistes qui
étaient traînés en justice
pas juste titre et donc ça a pu sauver
bon nombre d'entre nous parce qu'on a pu
prouver avec les vidéos qu'on avait rien
à se reprocher et que des policiers ont
pu être condamnés
donc si les visages sont floutés comment
on fait quoi comment on fait pour pour
donner les images par exemple à la
presse pour que ça puisse se savoir où
est la justice ça va être un petit peu
compliqué à les policiers sont souvent
qu est-ce qui est ce qu'on les reconnait
pour autant on ouvre le débat évidemment
mais qu'en est-il de de la relaxe
aujourd'hui d'eric drouet figure du
mouvement qui s'était mis en retrait
votre mouvement ne veut toujours pas de
leader
c'est toujours la philosophie écoutez
c'est toujours une base d'horizontalité
maintenant ce qu'on appelle figure parce
que les médias leur ont donné plus plus
la parole que d'autres c'est face et
tout le rôle qu'ils ont eue mois pour
moi je les vois un petit peu comme des
boucliers ces gens là et ils ont ils ont
pas eu le le retour sur investissement
si je peux parler comme ça ils ont eu
plus de problèmes qu'autre chose
alors que c'était des gilets jaunes
parmi les gilet jaune
donc ils ont voulu prendre eric du web
pour faire un exemple mais force est de
constater qu'ils se sont bien rendu
compte que encore une fois c'est un
manifestant parmi les manifestants donc
il n'avait pas plus de responsabilités
que ça maintenant moi je suis très
content pour lui qu'ils se soient mis en
retrait c'est naturel parce qu'il avait
quand même des affaires judiciaires
maintenant qu'elles sont derrière lui
j'ai cru comprendre qu'ils seraient là
demain d'un tant mieux parce que la
colère est toujours présente et grossit
de plus en plus ça vous me l'apprenez
merci
qu'en est il que pensez vous de cette
crise sanitaire on a vu que c'était
souvent des des gens de votre mouvement
qui étaient là et qui ont continué à
travailler à faire fonctionner le pays
pendant cette période de confinement
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est aussi une
de vos revendications le fait d'être
davantage écoutés parce que vous êtes
essentiel aussi où le travail en tout
cas et est essentielle à la nation jeu
en ce que les français et d'exécutif ont
pu voir que effectivement c'était entre
guillemets les petites mains les
premiers de travail comme nous on les
appelle parmi nous qui étaient les mains
dans le charbon qui ont continué à
alimenter les rayons qui ont nettoyé et
c'est donc on pensait quand même qu'ils
avaient compris que ces métiers là était
quand même primordial surtout on l'a vu
avec le confinement tout le monde est
allé faire les courses on était content
de retrouver les produits dans les
rayons et c'est donc on pensait que
l'exécutif avait compris mais force est
de constater que non parce que rien
n'est fait rien n'est fait pour pour les
revaloriser un minimum merci beaucoup on
suivra en tout cas donc le redémarrage
de votre mouvement demain en direct sur
rt france
merci jacques mignaux d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur arte france